(Critic) Hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you don't have to if there's anything Avatar: The Last Airbender has taught us
Is that there's a yin to every yang.
For every good there is a bad and it's our duty to acknowledge them in order to keep balance
Considering how Avatar is my favorite show of all time it only makes sense in other of this philosophy to go over
What many you would probably see as a controversial issue.
That of course being the bad episodes of Avatar. For no particular reason, I will now duck
(guns fire)
Let me go into a little bit more detail
In my opinion
There's really no such thing as a bad episode of Avatar. Even the weakest episodes have something of value in word that goes beyond
What's presented in most family-friendly shows. But, if we want to acknowledge the best it also makes sense to acknowledge the worst
So we can figure out how to continually make the art grow stronger
So I see no fault in looking over the not bad
But just not as good episodes of one of the greatest TV shows of all time (Malcolm) uh, Critic?
Are you sure that's wise?
(Critic) Look, we're all adults, and we're going to talk about this in an adult way.
So what's the problem?
(Tamara) Just that when people see the word "worst" in the title they might think the wrong thing
(Critic) Well...
That's technically what it is isn't it? The worst of the best?
I'm not afraid of a bunch of fanboys and fangirls, especially for a franchise. I love so much
(Tamara) Okay
(Malcolm) Shame your life had to end this way *tsking noise*
(Critic) I'll be fine. Thanks, so without further ado
*tsking noise continues*
(Critic)Do you mind? I can hear your *tsk tsk tsk* all the way in here?
(Malcolm) That's an even bigger shame! *tsking noise*
(Critic) SHUT UP! *tsking stops and then starts again, and then stops*
Like I was saying we're gonna look at the top eleven. Yeah, it is good episodes up an all-around great series
Why top 11 because I like to go one step Beyond so sit [back] and enjoy the top [11]?
technically worst episodes of avatar the last airbender
Boiling Rock part 1
In this episode zuka and [Sokka] try to break out the prisoners from their failed invasion by getting capture
themselves and working with sookie to find a way out in all fairness very little is wrong with the premise the
Development even the kick-ass action scenes that come from it the problem is minor
But still a noticeable one that being why is there a part one at all?
Seriously this could have been just one episode in fact if it was it could have possibly been the most tightly written
Action-Packed one there ever was but instead we get time dedicated to planning an escape from the prison
Putting that plan to motion and ultimately having a fail
Which of course leads to the second planning of the escape from the prison and a second attempt to put it into motion?
that one succeeds
but well
Why the hell did they just edit the first one out then were they just?
Short an episode so they decided to stretch one out a little more don't get me wrong. There's a lot of character
There's a lot development it furthers the story, but I think all that probably could have been fit into one [episode]
Maybe with just a tiny cut here there. I guess in [some] respects. It's a bit more realistic
Not to have the first attempt succeed, but it's also realistic that appa would most likely eat momo at some point
But that doesn't mean to want to see it when the episode finally does get going with the real plan in part [two]
It's great. It's a lot of fun
It's just [seeing] through part one that isn't bad, but it isn't necessary either probably a nitpick
But like I said this is the worst of the best, so you'll probably see a couple more you happy now. I'm never happy
number 10
the Serpent's Pass
Team Avatar has to pass through a dangerous route to get to the city of Ba sing se
after agreeing to take a pregnant couple with them and being reunited with sookie the team tried their best not to get gobbled up by
A giant beast while also [working] out their emotional problems again, not a bad premise, but the emotional problems
They're working through just artists engaging compared to other episodes for example Sokka gets
Overprotective sookie because he has lost a loved one before, but we know how it's Gonna end [right]?
He's is up as she convinces him that she can take care of herself
Just by getting captured later, but come on. That's like setting a bowling pins egg is still dealing with the loss of appa
But we've got a lot of [that] a much more intense episode prior
So again it [just] kind of feels like leftovers heck even zuko's problem seems pretty mundane
Just trying to get more food with Jets Gang and a [ferry] um
[on] [Earth]
Not that these are bad problems to focus on but when you combine them all together and also throw in a mother giving birth
Just kind of a slow one even the serpent compared to all the other great designs
They've had on the show is not especially that memorable
[I] mean, what was the combination of animals on that one the dragon from [Zelda] 2 with a novelty map?
[I] know means awful, but even as the slower episodes go this one. Just felt really stuck
I guess if that was the intention of the episode it definitely worked nothing major
not
Jet
fresh off the last episode jet has a great morale with a great payoff but
Kind of the less than thrilling character to do it with [jet] on the surface seems interesting enough
He's like a young robin hood trying to teach the fire nation a lesson
But goes too far when he tries to take out innocent civilians this creates some interesting baggage for the character
But for the most part he's just kind of a good-looking thief
He's there to throw another wrench into aang and Katara's romance and mostly just be a good look Boyle [is] nothing
He has no character. It's just not very much again by avatar standards. It's not that he's annoying or unpleasant
It's just we've seen the good-looking hero, who it turns out is [not] the hero and has a stubborn side
That's just never going to change most of us know it's coming and we're just kind of waiting [for] it to take its course
While the more allah teaches about innocence caught in the crossfire of war is certainly a strong one
[I] do wish there was a slightly better character to get across with if he was even more memorable
Maybe this could have been an even bigger deal the kid equivalent of Magneto or something as is he's not bad
But [like] the episode proved he's certainly not everything he was built up to be
Doesn't seem fair does it
number
Cave of two lovers the romance on avatar has always been one of the weaker points and lee's praying in guitar anyway
It's not that I can't see them together. It's that we have to go through a lot of the same cliches
We've gotten in other romances where they'll always be overly awkward which leads to a misunderstanding
Which leads to them being angry at each other and of course leads to them both realizing they were wrong
Say directed by Gary Marshall, and we got a [wrap] in this episode
We go through most of that in a setting [called] the cave of two lovers on the one hand
I'm kind of glad all the romantic comedy cliches were kind of gotten out in this one episode
but still I don't think you needed them to begin [with]
Falling in love is interesting enough without having to feel you always have to throw in this constant bickering
This continuing formula of the couple that argues all the time, but that somehow gets together in the end
I mean, why does there have to be so much bickering in so many romances don't they know that's what marriage is for
You know they're going to get together
So I never got why they tried to drag it out as long as [they] did they can get together early on
There's nothing wrong with it. [have] them be a couple afterwards work through a relationship stuff
That would happen after you decide to be a couple come on. There's other areas to go in this and granted
It's not office bad
But it has those romantic comedy trademarks that avatar just seems to be above
But still when a nice scene does play out
It does seem legitimately nice, and we do see Sokka deal with this world's interpretation of well hippies
so is by no means a loss, but I think this couple can definitely be strong enough without the Julia Roberts tropes and
God help you if you actually make guitar laughs that way
number seven
the Waterbending Master
After making their way to the Northern water tribe
Guitar is horrified to discover that they don't teach women and girls how to fight
But only how to heal so she faces off with the prejudice of Aang's new Master to show sisters are doing it for themselves
I never know how to feel about episodes like this [on] the one hand. Yeah. There's always going to be people or cultures
We're gonna be prejudiced about anything Gender [Ray's] appearance
whatever
So it makes sense to stand up against that
On the other hand isn't the message done better if instead of preaching about what you want to see you just show it
Growing up as a little boy. I always loved gosselin from [Darkwing] [duck] and babs from tiny toons
[I] didn't care [that] they were girls, and that's because the show didn't care either
They were just funny characters that were part of the group
So I never had any problem with them however when the troupe of girls proving they can do what boys can do comes in?
Always feel like it's making the character more
Statistic than a person and guitar is definitely not that neither her gender nor any prejudice against her was her identity
So this plotline didn't seem especially needed as a kid if the people in the world you love accept something
It's more likely you're gonna accept it too, but again on the [other] hand
We do know all this bullshit does happen in the world, and there's always going to be idiot douchebags out there who enforce it
So it's probably good to be prepared [for] it, right
It's hard to say what the best route to take is but with this episode
We all know exactly what that route is going to be
She's going to win him over and of course he's going to teach her in the end
Even if you are gonna take this road, isn't there a slightly different way you could do it some variations something
We didn't see coming [no]
We did get some great water bending action great shots of the city and hey
It's still these great characters being great characters
I guess all I'm looking [for] is a little bit more variety in the message or at least the teaching of the message
But again, I still got to see Katara. Do what Katara does and is pretty awesome, so I can't complain too hard
You can knock me down
number [six]
Sokka's Master
This actually ties into the same argument. I had with the last one only this time
It's a bit of a different prejudice [Sokka] feels bad because he's not a bender like anka Taro or [toth]
Because of this he feels totally useless so he finds a master to teach him the art of sword fighting and being a great fighter
He even manages to put a sword made from a meteorite together
So now he never has to feel left out ever again the strange thing about this episode
Is that through the previous seasons they've tried to convince us Sokka had a point and in my opinion
They succeeded Sokka was more than just the comic relief
He was the idea guy the one who thought out of the box [the] one who at times
Could be a little too nutty
But always came through with what he needed to come through with he even already had a weapon his trusty boomerang and we all
Associated it with him. So the idea of acting like he had no pardon everything
I was going on didn't seem necessary
He was important not just for last before strategic planning
and he was good at it right even so this whole episode about him trying to feel redeemed and valuable didn't really pay off because
We already thought he was again
It's drawing attention to a prejudice you probably weren't prejudiced against and possibly didn't even know was a thing Sokka's fine
[no] improvements needed
It's almost like the [creator's] were anticipating a backlash for [him] that as far as I know never came
Who can't love Sokka Suckas great never change for anyone big guy keep it real water tribe?
number five
The Swamp [a] lot of things are hinted at in this episode
But many of them don't turn out coming very far
The team is lost in a swamp that gives visions of the past present and even future
While trying to figure out what it means they're also trying to outrun a couple of swamp rats who want to eat their animal companions?
For dinner the ending is definitely interesting as it delivers a message about how all things are connected
[and] to its credit in a very creative [way], but there's one major problem. You're in the swamp a
Disgusting dark bug filled gloomy ass swamp who the hell wants to be in a swamp there isn't any fun
Goodness being like a nice forest or a creepy forest or an I don't know which is anything
But a swamp do we really have to focus on this world's version of Duck dynasty
[I] think we can survive without that
We also get the return of zuko as the blue spirit as well as haunting memories from Katara and Sokka's past
But none of them seemed to especially go far in the long run the only thing that really plays a big [part] is aang seeing
A vision of toph who would eventually become his earthbending teacher
But aside from that rich is stuck in this nasty-ass swamp and don't get me wrong
I know a lot of his don't judge a book by
It's cover and honestly they did get a lot more wisdom entertainment than I would have thought they would [have] in this environment
But yeah the avatar version of deliverance not a fan
the painted Lady
[I] think we all kind of cringe when we hear an episode of anything is going to be about the
Environment and yes, the environment is important save the Earth all that good stuff, but let's face it guys
[it's] so rarely done
Well truth be told there's only two family related shows I can think of that handle it with any subtlety or intelligence
Sonic the Hedgehog a knife in choking there actually is a subtle environment message in there much better [than]
That's our show
And of course avatar the whole show definitely has a strong tie to Nature health the nations are named after the four
Elements, but it was never rubbed to much in your face that is with the exception of this well
No way is bad as other environmental messages
Why did the Show feel they needed one?
Addressing pollution and saving the Earth the show's already kind of been doing that with its subtlety hasn't it
Katara is concerned because while they're not supposed to interfere with the fire nation yet a village is starving and losing their home to pollution
So she disguises herself as the spirit of the river known as the painted lady to feed and heal all those who need it
It brings up a good debate on how far does one go before interfering with other cultures
But like many of you when you see a big bad
Factory Spewing sludge and young kids who control the elements try to help I only think of one thing
again as most
Environmental episodes of [family] shows go this one is not honestly that bad, but compared to what the rest of the show had been
Naturally giving us all this time this one's just a hint too obvious you wouldn't mind keeping that a secret by the way would you?
No problem
number three
The Headband now. I'm just gonna Say it avatar
Really?
Really of all the movies for avatar [-] Joyfully rip-off we get a bizarre version of footloose
[yeah], what loose hanging the Gang had to sneak through the fire nation dressed as civilians?
But aang gets picked up by [a] school and sure enough. He's now getting an education
The only downside is the kids aren't allowed to have fun what to do
Blow a party inviting all the kids and show them it's okay to enjoy yourself be silly and of course
Even dance [a] part of me really [laughs] that [this] episode even exists. I mean Lord
Avatar does what loose it's just so strange that you know the creators of this just had to do it
But dude this is the second [episode] of the last season and the last one was [pretty] heavy
This is [the] follow-up work in it. I mean. Yeah, okay
Maybe you need something light after so much drama, but this is really light and really
[freakin] corny yeah betar has had a lot of corny moments
But this is throwing a prom in [the] heartland of your enemy. I don't know. It's just a little
Really?
footloose!?
Kevin bacon [they] [did] the Footloose on top of doing the obvious follow your dreams message
It does give us a nice chance to see again that not all the fire nation is made up of evil
Foot soldiers. There are normal people with normal kids and unlike the ones before we get a little
[bit] of that gentleness rather than just see it. It's cute
It's innocent,
but if I told someone, this was my
Favorite all-time show and this was the episode they saw they'd think there was fucking mental if you like seeing avatar do footloose that fine
It's not like I can't see why it's just
Footloose!?
Bato of the water tribe when I first saw this it was my least favorite
episode, why, because I felt it
went against everything that [Aang] was.
Our team comes across an old friend from the water tribe named Bato.
As Bato recommends them to look for their father and finds a letter from exactly him Sokka and Katara's Dad.
Afraid Sokka and Katara will leave him
He actually hides the letter destroying the possibility of them being reunited
I couldn't believe it when I saw this episode
This is a Aang, friggin Aang who destroyed this opportunity for his two best friends whom he owes everything to.
for seeing what's left of their family, it just it didn't feel like him
I know
He's a kid and kids make emotional mistakes, but they've established him as being smart and sensitive he, grows up an environment
[that] is nothing
But this with everything that Aang's characters seemed in what he was taught this just didn't seem [like] him
It seemed downright Alien even Sokka and Katara's seemed a little harsher than usual, but to be fair
It's kind of hard to blame them. This was a pretty big deal
Now with that said there are [a] lot of good elements looking back on again
We got to meet Jun the [Bounty] [hunter] there was still some awesome fighting
And it does I guess cement them as a family unit. It's the only time though
I've ever seen this character not feel like the character
Which I suppose is good seeing how lots of shows make that mistake often and this one only [slips] up [once]
Some good fighting and still an overall good message, but man, I will never get that choice
And the number one worst episode of oh you [timmy]. You know it's the great divide
Yep, the universally hated episode by practically every avatar fan. It doesn't connect much to the grand story
It doesn't further much character, and it's considered by many to be a complete waste of time
[so] is it really as bad [as] all that?
well
let's take a look at the set up two feuding tribes find they have to cross through a canyon called the great divide and
Ain´t decides to help them through it [trying] constantly to be the peacekeeper all the tribe can do is bicker
Complain shout yell and blame each other for everything
And I hope you're a fan of that because that is literally what takes up the majority of the episode after listening to oh?
I don't know twenty four minutes of this egg finally lets them know that
They're feuding was all based on a bogus
History that this great big warring few was actually based on two little kids fighting over a ball
That's actually a pretty funny idea the tribes decide
There's no reason to hate each other and that the honor they were fighting for [can] be reached if they all decide to forgive
The Catch Aang is a fucking liar
You could call it lying what I need the whole thing off. You did not
That is so wrong now. Where's that custard tart and good Lord remember?
How we talked about breaking character in the last one we're on the peaceful?
Airbending philosophy of Balance and truths as I say just make shit up
If you can't find the best route just lie about it. No harm done. So not only do you have an episode
That's mostly complaining and arguing even among the main characters
But you also have would have been a clever message about prejudice reduced down to if someone's a racist lie your ass off
These we could have had something if angus stopped talking and the two
Separated but straight up making up a story explaining years of real hurt. This is a weird message
They're trying to Convey
I'm not even sure what you're supposed to take out of it
Sometimes lying is good [the] needs of the short-term solution Outweigh the needs of the long-term solution
The truth will set you free only when it's convenient
This episode was so hated that even in the series recap. They act out the scene pretending like it never happened
Look, it's the great divide the biggest canyon in the Earth Kingdom
[let's] keep flying. It's clunky. It's misguided. [it's] confused much like the great divide. It's a great mess
Let's keep flying
but
Even with that said I still don't think it's a bad episode
Because I still stand by [that] there are no bad episodes even that. It's weak as avatar was
Fantastic because no matter what it always had great characters great story great
animation and the ability to take children and adult
100% seriously it's a show unlike any other we've ever seen yes
There's a lot of things that aren't good and the great divide, but the animation is still great
I still like following these characters. I still like hearing their performance. I still want to see where the story is Gonna
Go, that's the incredible hole that the show has even when it's not great
There's still great things in it, and that's why avatar will always be one of a kind
I
Am seeing this is all about keeping the grand balance it only makes sense next week to do the top 11 greatest avatar episodes
There will they call me the fuck down
I don't know critic. There's still two minutes left in the time-barred
Something could still go wrong. [yeah]. Yeah like there's somebody out there who could possibly do something bad [to] you oh
Yeah
What are people gonna do complain on message boards [right] mean?
Comments, show me one person who would actually be crazy enough to cause me physical harm because of this list
Sir, I just received word from the [avatar] [fanbase]
They say the Nostalgia Critic has disgraced the franchise by doing a top 11 worst episodes list how do you wish to respond?
Tell them I'll be arriving in one week's time. I look forward to winning back the fanbase
Yes, sir. Okay. Let's go